players watching this video comment down
below how to play forward on multiplayer
this is gonna be so fun guys hi I'm
Hannah and I'm the world's okay it's mom
and I have a very busy life between my
husband and my two kids and my full-time
job my time is really split so I want to
get back to focusing on quality
one-on-one time so I'm gonna try
something I'm gonna give each of my kids
their dream day one entire day for them
to do whatever they want with just me
now I'm nervous about what they're gonna
pick but I'm really excited to try this
so wish me luck my whole life is kind of
this balance of trying to delegate time
and energy equally between both of my
kids and my husband and we don't often
do one-on-one time I don't know if this
is just me or if this is a universal
thing everybody in my house tries to
talk to me at the same time sounds like
this might but only a few dollars
is very hard
what so the two roles for these dream
days are one it has to be something
possible that I can actually accomplish
so no rocket ships to the moon no
visiting Mars rule number two is it has
to be something that can fit in one day
so it can be multiple small things that
fit within a day or one big thing but
I'll leave that up to them
we started with Jackson's dream day on a
Saturday he woke up at like 6:00 in the
morning you're all dressed and ready it
is 6:30 in the morning it's his day his
choice but like come on we won't sleep
in a little bit just a different kind of
dream he decided to start the day off
with a big breakfast at our local diner
then skateboarding at our favorite skate
park followed by ice cream and ending
the day with video games and pizza at
home we're here were the only people in
the parking lot except one person but I
think they work here we might have the
restaurant to ourselves we're very early
okay
a long and hard about his strength
I never let him take whatever he wants
to drink keep in mind we are both
skateboarding so you wanna be super
heavy with root beer I'm slowly starting
to look like the mom who does not
monitor her kids diets ever but I swear
my kids are healthy generally holy moly
I let him order whatever he wanted at
the restaurant because it's his day I
swear I'm a good mom I swear don't you
being just one-on-one with him it's just
so weird how quickly time flies because
Jackson is seven and I can take him out
to breakfast and we can sit and have a
conversation shut this down oh my gosh
meet ourselves
stop the next stop was skateboarding and
we had a little hang-up got my helmet on
I feel ready except I stood on a
skateboard and I could not even stand on
it I was so afraid so instead of going
to a skate park which was our original
plan we're just going to go to a quiet
sidewalk by our street so I can learn
the basics so Matt is really good at
skateboarding so he's taught both the
boys they go a lot it's their little
activity that they do together and
that's when I stay home and watch true
crime shows I am not coordinated I am
NOT sporty Oh oh my gosh push it and I'm
too scared to skip a shot I'm really
proud of myself I actually got some
movement I kind of like ran into a pole
once but that was okay no one got hurt
I'm saying I was okay but that's not
true whenever I lie my eyes water up and
I just really like by saying that I was
good at it just watch the footage you
didn't see how I did okay your turn
Jackson really took this as an
opportunity to show off how much better
he was than I am at skateboarding he was
like mom wasn't so hard as he's like
zooming off and I'm just like food yeah
I think it meant a lot to him that I
tried it
because they've wanted me to try it for
a really long time
the fact that I did it for him made him
feel really would I do it again
no I don't know if you guys noticed but
there's a lot of trash on this street so
we put gloves on and we're gonna pick up
this trash before we go on to our next
adventure because Jackson is really
really thoughtful about the environment
it was his idea
it gives me hope for the future that at
7 Jackson can recognize when something's
not good for the environment and takes
it upon himself to to do something about
it he has a lot of empathy which is
something you really want your kid to
have and it's hard to teach trash glove
high-five nice so it was really hot out
skateboarding was done so it was ice
cream time ice cream means frozen yogurt
so we're gonna try a little fun game
with our frozen yogurt without Jackson
thought of I choose momma's and
she chooses rock and here's a rule you
have to make the ever you have to make
them good
I was very generous with my flavors and
toppings and I thought I really created
a nice frozen yogurt Bowl I got you cake
batter here I was very sour patch and
dole with with animal cookies Remo
sprinkle chocolate chips gummy worms
gummy bears
popping Bova a maraschino cherry and I
think that's it would you get me old
room make slits tart
he also poured like half a cup of nerds
on top
I can see where the effort was cold
rural nerds
it was it was frozen yogurt are you
alone
I do love it whenever I lie my eyes
water up he just really overloaded it
with toppings that he loves larger nerds
but it was really cute because he was
excited to watch me eat it question for
you what's your favorite thing about
yourself I have a good family favorite
thing about your brother
he's funny kind
sometimes what's your favorite thing
that we do together
having fun
after ice cream we still had one thing
left to do for his stream day and just
like skateboarding it's an activity that
I delegate to their dad the next order
of business I'm Jackson's dream day
video games and I felt like a high
school boy service on the floor I cute
and the knowledge boo Mulligan I still
got it I can still wolf down half a
pizza while I'm playing video games she
won't sleep for tonight wait so he's
gonna play on the switch and I'm the
plan where do I'm sure a lot of you like
fortnight out there and you play it and
I'm sorry this is not a criticism of
fortnight please help me help me
understand you're gonna die why we have
to go inside I had fun with you Miki
today was really fun today was really
thanks for picking awesome things for us
to do thank you for picking awesome
things for we did dude I didn't pick
anything you did I think you did you
thank yourself thank yourself it was so
simple but it seemed like it was such a
full day and we had so much fun together
we should do this more often huh
we should do a screw her outfit things
huh he's just he's really funny and he's
really sweet and he gets really excited
about the things that he loves I just
loved that about him
so it was fun to experience it one on
one we got Jackson's dream day in the
books the next day was Wyatt's guess
whose dream day it is not the person who
eats his boogers nice yeah
if you watch the show you know why it's
a little bit different and his dream day
was all about being fancy and self-care
you ready no oh my god stop eating your
voice so we start the day off with
Starbucks followed by errands including
going to target while we're at Target
we'll get some self-care items - then
come home and have a fun Spa time after
that we'll eat sandwiches and then go
horseback riding after we're all cleaned
off we're going to read books in bed and
do Tuttle's Tuttle's our cuddles but he
can't say cuddles yes and I hope he
never learns how ok we are headed to
Starbucks do you know what you want at
Starbucks you know yeah Oh Clawd
macchiato yeah we got to figure out a
way to get that with no coffee
I wanted to accommodate his choice but
obviously he can't have caffeine so we
got a caffeine free cloud macchiato and
he really felt fancy with that mm-hmm
Derek stole like 12 marketers or do it I
handed him my camera and he is not a
vlogger yet but he's getting there
we're having me on speed to light
microphone
[Music]
what's your favorite store in the world
target targets what's this on your hand
Oh make your jab it's a glove are you
wearing it to Target
why I can't have your hand oh okay so
you better wear a glove what is on our
shopping list I don't know what it is
just the experience of shopping he loves
it mom thanks max and face masks we got
lots of supplies for what was to come
alright is Jay up and running
so we have our candles I made us a spa
fruit plate with of course Oreos I got
these face masks I don't know where they
came from but they were straight-up
scary
show me why it's little face it's a
little too small for a face bisque and
you look she just looks so cute
sometimes I forget that he's only four
years old because he has kind of this
old soul and he'll hold perfectly still
for a face mask I don't think that's
typical for his age you're sleeping
turning green oh so while he was in the
bath with his bath bombs I fed him fruit
from this Bob let her clean back I'm not
I'm just feeding you do I think I'm
spoiling him probably
I hope I'm helping him understand his
worth if you don't have someone feeding
you strawberries in the bathtub
leave them how's your spa time Gary what
do you want to be when you grow up to
our youtuber okay what's your favorite
thing about your brother playing drugs
your favorite thing about me ah we're
gonna finish this up and go to our next
stop please next stop
so after spa day was horseback riding it
seems a little counterproductive that we
did all the spa stuff before going out
to the dust and dirt but we had to get
like a lesson slot at the horseback
riding place and that's cool and we got
and so that's what we did it oh man I'm
tired he's tired he was sleeping and I
had to wake him up
I think he was a little confused at the
beginning cuz the nap hadn't been quite
long enough you ready to do it I'm gonna
be a horseback rider but he did get into
it he's not a kid who gets outwardly
excited often it takes a lot to get him
to be like over the moon like cheering
and jumping and stuff - awesome both
awesome let's go to our next stop
you excited oh my gosh so after a long
horseback riding lesson
all white wanted to do was finish his
day with books and Tuttle's I'm proud of
myself you're proud of yourself for your
reading I'm really proud of you too
we helped take Caleb oh nice maybe it's
a younger sibling thing because that
bedtime all of a sudden he turns into
this kid who just wants five thousand
hugs from me and if I don't cuddle him
before bed it is the end of the world I
have a child in my armpit ouch look at
that he's really heavy and he's in my
armpit
oh that's why we put up with his sass
he's so cute I'm gonna miss this so much
when he doesn't want to do it anymore it
takes forever at night but then I remind
myself that in two years he's not gonna
want this anymore so I'll take it while
I can taking the weekend to give my kids
their dream days really highlighted to
me how much more of that we really need
to do as a family
juggling siblings and everybody else
things get buried and things get lost
and you you don't have that full
undivided attention I definitely got a
better sense of the things my kids love
right now and the things they prioritize
and it was really nice to be able to
participate in all that with them it's
so weird they my kids feel like many
adults you know I'm not gonna cry my
trigger is talking about my kids getting
older and I it's that's fine that they
and they are getting older no nope
they're in graduate they're gonna go to
college they're not gonna call me
they're gonna call me once a week and
then they're gonna see me on Christmas
and it's gonna be fine needs kids anyway
so that's all I got for today I'm Hannah
and have you ever had a dream day have
you given your kids a dream day if so
let me know how it went in the comments
or if you have any other ideas for us
for a dream day leave that in the
comments as well know if you'll please
excuse me I'm gonna brush up on my
fortnight while Jackson isn't here til
next time I don't know the buttons
[Music]